is Donald Trump still eligible to be
president of the United States does the
14th Amendment prevent him from running
well as we all know Trump was indicted
four times in New York Florida
Washington DC and Georgia prosecutors in
two of those cases allege that he tried
to overthrow the results of the 2020
election lawyers from the citizens for
responsibility and ethics in Washington
or crew have just filed a lawsuit
alleging that Trump's role in the
January 6 Riot disqualifies him from
running for president because of Section
3 of the 14th Amendment which is known
as the disqualification Clause this
Clause says that a person cannot hold
office in the United States if they have
previously taken an oath as an officer
of the United States and have engaged in
an Insurrection or Rebellion so this
raises unique questions that the Supreme
Court has yet to answer is the president
an officer of the United States for the
purposes of Section 3 did Trump engage
in activity that amounts to an
Insurrection or rebellion and how would
disqualification even be enforced well
let's find out the text of Section 3 the
14th Amendment reads no person shall be
a senator or representative Congress or
elector or president and vice president
or hold any office civil or military on
the United States or under any state who
having previously taken an oath as a
member of Congress or as an officer of
the United States or as a member of any
state legislator or as an executive or
judicial officer of any state to support
the Constitution of the United States
shall have engaged in Insurrection or
Rebellion against the same or given a or
Comfort to the enemies thereof but
Congress may buy a vote of two-thirds of
each house remove such disability
Section 3 of the 14th amendment was
passed after the Civil War and here's a
recap of those events for Florida
students who might have missed this
particular history the southern states
illegally seceded from the Union
declared themselves the Confederate
States of America and then waged a war
against the Federal Government after
these South's defeat the people who
rebelled against the United States
wanted to be involved in government men
who had violated their oath to support
the Constitution were elected to
congress this included officers who held
positions of high Authority in the
Confederacy such as for confederate
generals four Colonels several
Confederate congressmen and members of
Confederate State legislatures and even
the vice president of Confederacy
Alexander Stevens the Republicans who
wrote the 14th Amendment thought that
the people who tried to overthrow the
government by force shouldn't be allowed
to lead it Senator waitman Wiley of West
Virginia put it like this we would be
faithless to our trust if we allowed the
interests of the country and its future
peace and Welfare to begin disturbed by
men who have shown themselves faithless
in the past through their insane efforts
to destroy this government and that's
how we got Section 3 which prohibits
anyone who took an oath to support the
Constitution as a federal or state
officer and subsequently engaged in
Insurrection or Rebellion against it
from holding public office this
disqualification can be removed by a
two-thirds vote in Congress and this
removal option is a potentially
complicating factor that we'll get to in
just a minute so here's how section
three is supposed to work the amendment
is triggered when a person who is a
current or former government officer
takes note to support the Constitution
and then engages in covered conduct this
covered conduct is Insurrection
Rebellion or giving Aid or Comfort to
America's enemies if the official
commits the covered conduct they are
disqualified for life from holding any
banned office but the mechanism of just
qualification might be through a court
challenge where a judge decides or
through state law process where the
Secretary of State might decide who's
eligible on the ballot but we're not
entirely sure but in the first lawsuit
of its kind citizens for responsibility
ethics in Washington or crew sued the
Colorado Secretary of State alleging
that Trump is disqualified and can't be
on the ballot for the Republican primary
in that state although Section 3 has not
been tested often since the Civil War
last year crew successfully sued to
remove County Commissioner Coy Griffin
from Office Griffin is a former New
Mexico county commissioner who was
disqualified from office after being
convicted for his involvement in the
January 6th Riot so why did they bring
this lawsuit in Colorado because
Colorado law allows any eligible elector
within the meaning of the Colorado
statutes to file a challenge to the
Constitutional eligibility of candidates
in the 2024 Republican presidential
primary election now other states have
different mechanisms for challenging
qualifications of candidates before they
get on the ballot for example two
Florida residents attempted to get Trump
removed from the ballot in that state
but a federal judge in Obama appointee
ruled that citizens lack stand in that
state to challenge whether another
individual is qualified to hold public
office now the Constitution lays out the
qualifications for president that person
must be at least 35 years old a
natural-born citizen a resident of the
state that he or she represents and have
lived in the United States for at least
14 years there are also conditions that
disqualify a person from running the
22nd amendment prohibits a person who
has already been elected two terms as
president or served more than one and a
half terms from being elected as
president again the 12th Amendment
prohibits the president and vice
president from residing in the same
state and crew in the plaintiffs say
that the 14th Amendment is another type
of disqualification they argue that it
applies to Trump because he previously
swore an oath to support the
Constitution and then engaged in an
Insurrection now it's up for debate
whether the 14th Amendment acts as
another qualification for president like
the Asian residency requirement or
whether it functions as and after the
fact defense but was Donald Trump as
president an officer for purposes of the
disqualification Clause well the
Constitution does not define the word
officer however the Constitution refers
to the president holding an office 25
times and including the oath of office
Clause the presidency is an office in
the executive branch which makes it an
office of the United States and one who
holds an office as an officer so
according to crew Trump became subject
to disqualification under Section 3 when
he took an oath to support the
Constitution in the United States upon
assuming the Office of the President
Drew points out that Trump himself has
conceded in court filings that the
president of the United States is an
officer of the United States and point
taken but Trump's opinion on this matter
is not dispositive or consistent here's
what he said the other day quote almost
all legal Scholars have voiced opinions
that the 14th amendment has no legal
basis for standing relative to the
upcoming 2024 presidential election it's
just another trick being used by the
radical left Communists Marxist and
fascists to again steal an election that
their candidate the worst most
incompetent and most corrupt president
in U.S history is incapable of winning
in a free and fair election now that
being said there's a lot of debate among
legal Scholars as to whether the
president is an officer or not for the
purposes of the 14th Amendment now
Michael mukesi and attorney general
under George W bush argued in the Wall
Street Journal that the president is not
an officer under the 14th Amendment he
argues that the term officer of the
United States in other constitutional
Provisions shows that it refers only to
appointed officials not to elected ones
in U.S versus muat in 1888 the Supreme
Court ruled that quote unless a person
in the service of the government holds
his place by virtue of an appointment he
is not strictly speaking an officer of
the United States and Chief Justice John
Roberts reiterated the point in a case
where he said the people do not vote for
the officers of the United States and
mukesi also argued that the presidential
oath in Article 2 would be quote
Superfluous if the president's oath were
required by the general language of
article 6 and for what it's worth being
Casey's argument was enough to sway
Federalist Society founder Stephen
calabresi who had previously bought the
disqualification argument Colorado
Secretary of State Janet Griswold the
defendant in the Colorado lawsuit
slammed Trump as quote a liar who has no
respect for the Constitution she also
said quote if the Constitution
disqualifies the former president event
we have to uphold the Constitution
another Democratic Secretary of State
seems skeptical about the effort after a
group filed a lawsuit to keep Trump off
the ballot in Minnesota Secretary of
State Stephen Simon released the
following statement saying quote the
office of the Minnesota secretary of
state does not have legal authority to
investigate a candidate's eligibility
for office in the case of presidential
candidates the major political parties
will submit names of candidates to our
office for the presidential nomination
primary by January 2nd 2024. those
submissions will appear on the ballot
for the March 5th 2024 contest unless a
court says otherwise and he said the
matter has to be decided by December
14th to comply with state law meanwhile
other challenges are being filed
including a lawsuit filed by one of
Trump's primary opponents Texas Attorney
John Anthony Castro is running an
extremely long shot bid for the GOP
nomination against Trump and he filed a
lawsuit in New Hampshire seeking an
injunction that would force New
Hampshire Secretary of State to keep
Trump's name off of the ballot that
lawsuit is expected to be decided in the
New Hampshire Supreme Court by October
23rd and two Virginia citizens have
filed their own prose challenge to
Trump's appearance on the ballot in that
state so you can see how complicated
this is going to get as different states
have different primary deadlines and
disqualification procedures and Powers
apart from the legal issues but assuming
the president was an officer of the
United States that brings us to the next
question did Trump participate in an
Insurrection or Rebellion again those
words aren't defined in the Constitution
crew and the petitioners argue that the
Insurrection has a general public
meaning they say that a Civil War era
jury charge by Supreme Court Justice
Stephen field sitting as circuit Justice
explained that the quote existence of
the Confederate rebellion was a matter
of public notoriety and like matters of
general and public concern to the whole
country may be taken notice of by judges
and juries Justice field explained that
public documents such as proclamations
of the president and acts of Congress
were sufficient proof of the Confederate
rebellion's existence for purposes of
charges under a statute criminalizing
participation in Rebellion or
Insurrection now petitioners say that
under this interpretation of Section 3
the Insurrection is a matter of public
notoriety Trump participated in an event
that the public understood as an
Insurrection they point out that all
three branches of government and
bipartisan majorities of Congress
referred to January 6 as an Insurrection
and both Biden and Trump Justice
departments described those events as an
Insurrection and so did over a dozen
courts crew also points to the Griffin
Case where a court defined quote an
Insurrection as used in Section 3 as one
an assemblage of persons two acting with
a purpose to oppose the continuing
authority of the United States
Constitution three by force but one
thing is conspicuously missing from the
arguments the crew is making and that's
a requirement that a person be convicted
of an Insurrection or incitement or that
the person used violence to be clear
prosecutions for Insurrection under 18
USC 2383 or treason under 18 USC 2381 if
successful would almost certainly result
in a bar to holding any Office of the
United States but the petitioners are
arguing that Trump didn't need to be
convicted or commit an act of violence
or even be physically present during an
Insurrection to have committed an act
that triggers section three they pointed
out that during Reconstruction some
people were disqualified for having
previously held local office in
Confederate states even though they did
not take up arms in the Confederate Army
the argument is that engagement in an
Insurrection can include non-violent
overt Acts or words and furtherance of
the Insurrection including words that
incite provoke and courage or command
others to engage in insurrectionary
conduct sort of like a conspiracy now
these are the kinds of issues that
lawyers love and lay people absolutely
hate and if you have a similar issue and
need a great lawyer my firm the eagle
team can help if you've ever been in a
car crash suffered a data breach or need
workers comp we can represent you or
help find the right attorney who can and
for workers comp it's especially
important to get a lawyer as soon as
you're injured and not wait which you
can do right now just click on the link
in the description for a free
consultation with my team because you
don't just need a legal team you need
the eagle team link below and now back
to the 14th Amendment and petitioners
again point to the Griffin Case as
president the Court ruled that Griffin
engaged in Insurrection both by helping
to mobile lies and incite thousands
across the country to join the mob and a
judge determined that quote January 6
was an Insurrection under the
Constitution and that someone who helped
to incite it even if not personally
violent had engaged in Insurrection and
was disqualified from office and crew's
next argument is that quote president
Trump was indisputably the leader of the
January 6 mob without his false claims
of election fraud course of tactics
inflammatory rhetoric mob mobilization
promotion of political violence
instructions to march on the capital and
decisions to pour fuel on the fire
rather than tell the mob to disperse the
attack on the capital would not have
happened we're going to walk down and
I'll be there with you to the capital
and we're going to cheer on our brave
senators and congressmen and women
and we're probably not going to be
cheering so much for some of them
because you'll never take back our
country with weakness you have to show
strength and you have to be strong the
crew complaint spends over 120 Pages
explaining Trump's acts as they relate
to January 6. and in brief Trump led a
broad effort to disrupt the Electoral
certification on January 6 including
telling his fans to show up on that day
he spoke at the stop the steel rally and
during the riot he tweeted that Mike
Pence needed to summon the courage to
overturn the election results he ignored
people who urged him to intervene in the
riot instead exploiting it to pressure
Senators to delay or call off the vote
he didn't deploy a federal response to
the attack nor timely instruct the mob
to leave the capital and for those
reasons crew alleges that Trump is
barred from the ballot in Colorado and
under Colorado's presidential primary
election statute the secretary of state
is responsible for overseeing ballot
access for presidential primary
candidates including determining that
they meet all qualifications under
Colorado law and the petitioners asked
the court to require the Secretary of
State to independently investigate
Trump's constitutional eligibility and
rule that he is constitutionally
ineligible to serve as president now we
don't actually know if Section 3 is
self-executing and if it's not then
federal and state courts or election
authorities wouldn't have power to just
determine themselves the eligibility of
a candidate unless Congress enacts
legislation to permit it there's no
procedure in Section 3 explaining how it
should be implemented if Congress had to
enforce a disqualification Clause
through legislation it could set certain
guidelines such as requiring the person
to have been convicted of insurrection
and as summarized by a congressional
research report Congress initially
provided enforcement of Section 3 of the
14th Amendment through enactment of the
first Ku Klux Klan act in 1870. section
14 of that act directed the district
attorney in each district in which a
potentially disqualified person held
office to file a writ of quo warranto
against the office holder before a judge
however Section 3 says disqualification
can be removed by a two-thirds vote in
Congress and that's what happened when
reconstruction failed two years after
the Ku Klux Klan Act Congress passed the
and amnesty act by more than a
two-thirds vote in accordance with the
disqualification clause and the ACT
allowed most Confederates and their
sympathizers to serve as government
officials again and Congress could
theoretically pass the law of removing
the bar from Trump or anyone that
participated in January 6 but some also
argue that amnesty only operates
retrospectively for example when a group
of constituents challenged Madison
cawthorne's eligibility to hold office
because of his participation January 6th
the fourth circuit found that the antecy
given to Confederates does not apply to
later insurrections or treasonous acts
but given the lack of case law there's a
lot of debate here and not everyone
agrees that Trump is disqualified by
section three many lawyers claim that a
president is not an officer of the
United States and this argument rests on
an interpretation of the terms office
officer and official basically the idea
boils down to the fact that one can hold
an office without being an officer of
the United States Professor Josh
Blackman says that there might be a
significant difference between the words
of and under to it if a president is an
officer of the United States he can't be
disqualified but if he's a president
under the United States he can be but
that's far from a universal opinion uh
law professors William bod and Michael
Stokes Paulson uh say that there's no
evidence that the drafters of the 14th
Amendment were really using a secret
code in section three but the Supreme
Court might be willing to engage in this
kind of textual analysis in a 2010 case
called free enterprise fund versus
public company oversight board chief
justice Roberts wrote quote the people
do not vote for the officers of the
United States they instead look to the
president to guide the Assistance or
deputies subject to his superintendents
so the only precedent directly on point
here seems to point away from
classifying the president as an officer
and Blackman also points out that
section 3 only mentions members of
Congress members of state legislatures
and executive or judicial officers but
doesn't say the actual words president
or vice president he argues because the
amendment doesn't name the president the
president is not an officer who can be
disqualified and this gets into heady
originalism questions did the people who
wrote the disqualification Clause think
they were exempting the presidency from
the its reach did they really think it
was too dangerous for an ex-confederate
to be a senator but not for that person
to be president and there was a a
discussion about this issue when the
amendment was being debated Maryland
Senator reverty Johnson asked why the
President and Vice President were
excluded from the language because he
thought that the president vice
president should be disqualified if they
participated in an Insurrection and in
response Senator Justin Morrell with his
excellent sideburns assured him that
they were not quote let me call the
Senator's attention to the words or hold
any office civil or military under the
United States Senator Johnson then said
quote perhaps I am wrong as to the
exclusion from the presidency no doubt I
am but I was misled by noticing the
special exclusion in the case of
senators and representatives and that
was apparently the only time that the
matter was brought up during the debate
so should we assume everyone was
satisfied with the response with its
implication that the president was in
fact an officer or would we look to the
first textual interpretation saying that
it's clear that the president was
excluded based on the explicit text
lawyers are split on whether the
disqualification Clause is applicable to
people who didn't participate in the
Civil War though professors bought and
Paulson argue that the rule broadly
applies to any Insurrection or Rebellion
that the present day not only to former
Confederate officials and officers
during the post-civil War era they say
it's common for a rule that is drafted
to go further than its circumstances
which inspired its adoption but there's
also quite a lot of debate about whether
the courts would even exercise
jurisdiction over Trump's
disqualification now justiceability
refers to the types of matters that a
court can adjudicate and when a case is
not justiciable the court must dismiss
it standing is one example of
justiciability and the plaintiffs must
have suffered an injury in fact for a
court to resolve the dispute and another
justiceability issue is whether there is
a political question courts are not
supposed to deal with political
questions when doing so would require
the Judiciary to make policy decisions
exercise discretion Beyond its
competency or encroach on Powers the
Constitution vests in the legislative or
executive branches so the political
question Doctrine limits the ability of
federal courts to hear constitutional
questions even where other
justiciability requirements such as
standing and ripeness are met and with
the disqualification Clause there's a
legitimate argument that there is a lack
of judicially manageable standards
inside a case on the merits Section 3
leaves it to Congress to decide whether
to remove the bar there's no Clarity on
what Constitution Insurrection in this
context and courts will be reluctant to
step in and make that decision
independent of a criminal conviction
especially when it involves an election
of the highest Office of the land but of
course all this could be moved because
it seems extremely unlikely that the
current Supreme Court would endorse any
view that Trump has barred from
attaining the presidency especially
without a conviction for Insurrection
now obviously the 14th Amendment could
have been drafted more clearly which the
writers of the 14th Amendment could have
done with today's sponsor grammarly if
they had had AI assisted writing tools
in 1866 because grammarly accelerates
your writing process by generating and
modifying text instantly on demand
you'll be writing responsive thoughtful
emails and posts faster than ever it's a
huge productivity Boost Plus it's
grammarly which I've been using for
years so of course it will help you
write better than ever and unlike other
AI tools grammarly tailors its output
for your unique context it picks up on
key details and incorporates them into
what you're writing now I can set my
voice to be casual and empathetic for
example if I'm writing to friends or I
can set it to be more direct if I'm
writing to enemies like opposing counsel
and of course this is grammarly so it
helps fix poor writing in the first
place not that I would ever do that and
I can give it prompts to make something
shorter sharper or more exciting and one
of the coolest new features is the AI
reply tool which instantly creates or
replies your emails it picks up on
context and responds and calls up
exactly how you would want it's a huge
Time Saver and as a content creator I
have to do a lot of script writing and
with grammarly's features I can rewrite
my scripts to be more engaging instantly
and as a lawyer I have to do a lot of
writing and translating legal jargon
into something more readable and
grammarly's rewrite feature helps me
communicate more clearly the way that I
want to just make sure that you do all
the legal research yourself and you can
even use it for ideation to give it a
prompt to get ideas about what you want
to write about you'll be absolutely
amazed with what you can do with
grammarly and if you want to give it a
try you can get a 20 off discount by
going for the link that's on screen
right now or down in the description
again to get a 20 off discount from
grammarly all you have to do is click on
the link that's below and after that
click on this link over here for more
legal eagle or I'll see you in court